[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und einen
schönen guten abend die zeit die läuft
nach zwei stunden dann geht's los das
fußball em halbfinale deutschland gegen
frankreich wer wird finalgegner von
gastgeber england das wissen wir dann
später am abend die jetzt wissen wir
erst mal nur unsere großen
nachrichtenthemen heute
reisechaos in der ferienzeit weil das
bodenpersonal streik muss lufthansa fast
alle flüge streichen
neue waffen für die ukraine deutschland
will weitere gepard flugabwehr panzer
liefern
und kampf gegen die flammen die
waldbrände in sachsen und brandenburg
sind noch immer nicht gelöscht
mit lufthansa zu fliegen zurzeit
schwierig denn nachdem sich der konzern
und die gewerkschaft verdi in den
tarifverhandlungen verhakt haben streikt
seit dem frühen morgen das bodenpersonal
mitten in den sommerferien bedeutet dass
rund 1000 gestrichene flüge von den
flughäfen frankfurt und münchen und mehr
als 130.000 betroffene passagiere über
den warnstreik berichtet stefan
schlosser
manche bereiche sind komplett verwaist
an den umbuchen schaltern im frankfurter
flughafen hingegen ist der andrang heute
groß insgesamt hat die lufthansa mehr
als 1000 flüge gestrichen glücklich ist
wer einen alternativen flug bekommen hat
also wir haben festgestellt dass uns
sehr gut geholfen wurde ein flug wurde
annulliert und wir haben den nächsten
bekommen das wäre kein problem die
stimmung ist gerade ganz schön keller
der ganze stress mit fliege ein tag an
dem wir tagtäglich gestreikt werde
am vormittag machen die beschäftigten
des bodenpersonals vor der lufthansa
zentrale ihrem ärger luft verdi fordert
insgesamt 9,5 prozent mehr lohn
mindestens aber 350 euro pro monat und
einen mindestlohn von 13 euro pro stunde
den bietet lufthansa auch zusätzlich
insgesamt 250 euro mehr im monat plus
weitere 2 prozent gehaltssteigerungen ab
2023 mal positiven geschäftszahlen das
ist natürlich für uns überhaupt nicht
machbar bei preissteigerungen an der
tankstelle in bei der miete bei
lebensmitteln da fragt auch keiner
danach ob dies denn der lufthansa gut
geht sondern diese preissteigerungen
müssen die beschäftigtenzahlen deswegen
brauchen sie fixer lohnerhöhung
lufthansa bemängelt vor allem den
zeitpunkt des streiks die
tarifverhandlungen hätten doch gerade
erst begonnen das jetzt nach zwei
terminen bereits so ein streik
durchgezogen wird auf dem rücken der
reisenden ist überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehbar und verständlich
kommende woche wird weiterverhandelt
zumindest bis dahin soll es keinen
weiteren streit geben
und direkt am frankfurter flughafen ist
für uns isabel de la vega isabel bis 6
uhr morgens geht ja noch der warnstreik
fliegen denn dann die flugzeuge wieder
nach plan
also die lufthansa ist da sehr
optimistisch das management hat gesagt
ab morgen läuft wieder alles ganz
regulär mit kleineren abstrichen daran
müsste man aber schon zweifeln wenn man
bedenkt dass 130 tausend passagiere von
umbuchungen und streichungen betroffen
sind als es wird sicherlich noch mal ein
paar tage etwas ruckeln bevor das wieder
glatt läuft somalia die personaldecke
der lufthansa sehr dünn ist darauf zielt
ja auch der streik von verdi abwehr die
sagt wir haben zu wenig leute ihre zahl
zu schlecht bezahlt besser dann kommt
mehr leute zu lufthansa und dann werden
wir hier entlastet insgesamt muss man
sagen dass die lufthansa nicht zur ruhe
kommen wird nach diesem streik denn bei
den piloten gibt es schon eine
urabstimmung die wollen auch streiken
und das könnte dann die reisenden im
august treffen also schlechte zeiten für
die lufthansa und auch für die
passagiere vom frankfurter flughafen
isabel de la vega dankeschön
welche waffen soll die ukraine wann
bekommen darüber wird seit langem
politisch gestritten nach informationen
des zdf hat die bundesregierung die
herstellung von 100 panzerhaubitzen 2000
genehmigt davon dürfte auch die ukraine
profitieren kosten 1,7 milliarden euro
laut dem rüstungskonzern krauss maffei
wegmann
zudem gab die regierung grünes licht für
den export von insgesamt 30 flugabwehr
panzern vom typ gepard ines trams
berichtet
die ersten hat die ukraine nun erhalten
gepard flugabwehr panzer aus den
beständen der deutschen industrie auch
woher die munition kommt scheint nun
geklärt 30 grad sollen es mal werden so
hersteller krauss-maffei wegmann
ich kann ihnen bestätigen dass die
auslieferung der gepard
flugabwehrkanonen panzer die die ukraine
bei uns bestellt hat und deren export
die bundesregierung genehmigt hat
begonnen hat ich kann ihnen sagen dass
die bundesregierung den export von 30 g
panzern genehmigt hat
wir halten wort heißt es aus dem
verteidigungsministerium
die bundesregierung scheint
entschlossener als bisher die ukraine
mit schweren waffen zu unterstützen
gestern meldet man die lieferung von
mehrfach raketenwerfern heute bestätigt
die regierung dass das flugabwehrsystem
ihres geliefert wird
deutschland hat zugesagt die ukraine bei
der beschaffung zu unterstützen und so
wie der stand jetzt ist nach den
informationen die ich jetzt habe wird
die industrie in der lage sein das
system bis ende des jahres an die
ukraine zu liefern nach
zdf-informationen hat das
wirtschaftsministerium die produktion
von 100 panzerhaubitzen genehmigt auch
diese genehmigung deutet ein neues tempo
bei waffenlieferungen deutschlands
richtung ukraine an
fragen wir nach back und i'll manager
aus berlin chacon talla was hat es mit
dieser genehmigung auf sich er ist die
bundesregierung jetzt den weg frei macht
für einen rüstungsauftrag in dieser
größenordnung das lässt tatsächlich
aufhorchen denn sie ist auf kritisiert
worden dafür dass sie nicht genug tut
damit die herstellung von waffen die in
der ukraine gebraucht werden
beschleunigt wird für die panzerhaubitze
2000 kann man das jetzt nicht mehr sagen
allerdings muss man auch zwei
einschränkungen
hinzufügen zum einen lässt sich jetzt
aus dieser hersteller genehmigung noch
nicht genau sagen wie viele der 100
panzerhaubitzen dann auch tatsächlich in
die ukraine gehen dazu müsste man erst
einmal abwarten welche exportgenehmigung
irgendwann dann einmal erteilt wird denn
erst daraus ergibt sich wohin die
produzierten waffen auch tatsächlich
gehen und dann muss man dazu sagen dass
die produktion der panzerhaubitzen zwei
bis drei jahren normalerweise dauert man
kann sich also ausrechnen dass aus
dieser genehmigung jetzt keine
sofortigen folgen folgen für die
kampfhandlungen in der ukraine danke für
diese einordnung content manager
dann schauen wir auf das kriegsgeschehen
in der ukraine den ukrainischen truppen
ist offenbar ein angriff auf ein
strategisch wichtiges ziel bei personen
im süden gelungen dort sei die antonia
brücke beschossen worden meldete die
russische seite sie stehen noch habe
aber löcher und sei deshalb
vorübergehend nicht mehr befahrbar über
die brücke wird die von russland
besetzte stadt fässern mit nachschub
versorgt
die ukraine versucht also derzeit person
zurückzuerobern und hier können sie den
frontverlauf aussehen und hierbei
nikolov hat unser zdf-team soldaten an
der front begleitet ein bericht von dara
hassanzadeh
wir sind an der südfront bei nicolai es
schon seit wochen ist es ein kampf der
artillerie diesem bereich hier konnte
die ukrainische armee von russland
bereits zurückerobert
das fliegende drohnen und wenn sie
journalisten ausmachen dann nehmen sie
euch interessiert seit monaten leben die
soldaten der 59 brigade in
schützengräben unter artilleriebeschuss
bisher mussten sie die stellungen nur
halten doch ab jetzt sind sie teil der
ukrainischen großoffensive auf der sonne
doch die art zu kämpfen hat sich kaum
geändert
der beste freund des soldaten ist das
gewehr und die schaufel auf tour
die bunker kleben müssen bei jedem
vorrücken neu ausgehoben werden
inklusive raum für die feldküche immer
einsatzbereit der krankenwagen verletzte
werden sofort ins militärkrankenhaus
gefahren
die allermeisten soldaten werden durch
explosionen verletzt verursacht durch
artillerie geschosse
kaum schusswunden weil soldaten beider
seiten fast nie aufeinandertreffen der
krieg wird aus der ferne geführt
das schlachtfeld wird von anderen
genutzt von frauen die tatsächlich hier
kartoffeln ernten wir müssen weiter
arbeiten
es ist krieg aber wir wollen essen
wer ein sinnbild sucht was ukrainern
irland bedeutet der findet es hier
wegen des krieges konnte die ukraine
jahr millionen tonnen dringend
benötigtes getreide nicht exportieren
jetzt haben drei dafür bestimmte häfen
ihre arbeit wieder aufgenommen nach
angaben der ukrainischen marine sind der
hafen von odessa sowie zwei nahe
gelegene weitere wieder in betrieb die
schiffskonvois sollen durch das schwarze
meer richtung süden in istanbul werden
die exporte überwacht über die eröffnung
des koordinationszentrum es dort weiter
in der ukraine feuern sie tödliche
raketen aufeinander ab hier in istanbul
traten sie heute gemeinsam an den tisch
wortlos mit versteinerter miene
russische und ukrainische offiziere sie
sollen demnächst gemeinsam die
durchfahrt ukrainische getreide
frachtschiffe auf sicheren routen aus
diesem kontrollzentrum überwachen
begleitet von experten der türkei und
der vereinten nationen von einem
wesentlichen beitrag zur überwindung der
nahrungsmittelkrise sprach der türkische
verteidigungsminister
das zentrum wird die beteiligten
handelsschiffe registrieren und mit
satelliten und anderen mitteln alle
bewegungen technisch überwachen und dann
mit allen seiten und den vereinten
nationen koordiniert
vertreter aller vier parteien sollen die
schiffe bei ankunft und abfahrt in
istanbul inspizieren um waffentransporte
zu verhindern wann das erste schiff
ablegen kann ist unklar
wir arbeiten mit allen beteiligten hier
rund um die uhr um so schnell wie
möglich starten zu können
in odessa laufen bereits vorbereitungen
für die beladung der schiffe der export
von mehr als 20 millionen tonnen weizen
ist nach ansicht von fachleuten auch
eine logistische herausforderung
realistisch ist eine beratungszeit von
zwei bis drei tagen für ein
handelsübliches 40 bis 50 tausend tonnen
fracht schafft
bei besten voraussetzungen würde es dann
vier monate dauern um sie los und
speicher zu wehren falls sich russland
an seiner vertrags zusagen hält und die
helfen nicht weiter angreift
putin nutze weizen als kriegswaffe
kritisierte heute die präsidentin von
brot für die welt da knapp grün und
forderte gleichzeitig eine gerechtere
verteilung des weizens weltweit allein
in deutschland landeten 60 prozent des
angebauten weizens als tierfutter im
trog um den weltweiten hunger
kurzfristig zu ländern müssen die
reichen industrieländer die nothilfe
schnell und massiv erhöhen so brüllen
schon länger war ist klar die förderung
von e-autos wird reformiert und konkret
heißt das verringert ab 20 23 sinken die
zuschüsse deutlich bisher sind e-autos
noch in der klaren minderheit rund 30,9
millionen benziner und etwa 14,8
millionen diesel standen anfang april
rund
687.000 reine e autos und fast
623.000 plaques hebriden gegenüber
trotzdem ist anstieg bei den stromern
beachtlich innerhalb von vier jahren hat
sich ihre zahl verzehnfacht
sven glas hat mehr dazu
das hat sich was getan beim absatz von e
autos auch in diesem autohaus bei
stuttgart mehr als jedes dritte
verkaufte fahrzeug hier ist inzwischen
ein reines elektroauto oder ein plug in
hybrid die preise sind etwas höher und
insofern war die prämie oder ist die
prämie natürlich ein sehr bedeutsamer
kaufanreiz für die leute ein kaufanreiz
der künftig deutlich geringer ausfallen
wird bei reinen elektrofahrzeugen mit
einem listenpreis unter 40.000 euro
waren es bisher noch 6000 euro
staatliche förderung ab januar 2023 sind
es nur noch 4500
auch bei teureren autos gibt es
zukünftig weniger zuschuss außerdem wird
die fördersumme insgesamt gedeckelt
spätestens ende 2024 soll dann komplett
schloss seien angesichts der
milliardengewinne der automobilkonzerne
ist eine solche subventionierung auch
nicht mehr erforderlich hier setze ich
darauf dass über den markt impulse
kommen elektrofahrzeuge günstiger zu
machen bisher auch gefördert plug in
hybrid mit elektro- und
verbrennungsmotor für sie entfällt die
förderung schon ab januar 2023 komplett
im mittel ist es so dass die privat
genutzten plug in hybride und knapp die
hälfte elektrisch fahren bei den
dienstwagen sieht es nicht ganz so gut
aus da ist der realverbrauch ungefähr
bei acht litern weil nur zehn bis 15
prozent der kilometer elektrisch
gefahren werden die bundesregierung
betont mit den neuen regeln
haushaltsmitteln zielgerichteter
einzusetzen
die auto industrie fürchtet dass die
elektromobilität eingebremst werden
könnte auch weil autokäufer die prämien
erst bei der zulassung beantragen können
oft also monate nach der bestellung der
fördertopf könnte dann schon leer sein
auch bei den subventionen für
gebäudesanierung hatte die
bundesregierung änderungen beschlossen
zwar wird der fördertopf insgesamt
größer die fördersätze jedoch gekürzt
das heißt weniger geld also pro haushalt
etwa für den einbau einer wärmepumpe
dafür gab es bislang anteilig maximal
30.000 euro künftig sind es 24.000 für
den fensteraustausch sinkt die
staatliche beteiligung von bis zu 15.000
auf 12.000 euro
und das kabinett hat heute auch eine
erhöhung der gesetzlichen
krankenkassenbeiträge auf den weg
gebracht so soll der zusatzbeitrag und
kommenden jahr um 0,3 prozentpunkte auf
1,6 prozent des bruttoeinkommens
angehoben werden der grund den
krankenkassen werden 17 milliarden euro
fehlen 20 23 so
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
gegen die dokumente in kassel gibt es
neue antisemitismus vorwürfe in einer
ausgestellten broschüre sein
judenfeindliche zeichnungen zu sehen
ohne einordnung so die richter
informationsstelle antisemitismus in
hessen die dokumente wies die vorwürfe
zurück das werk sei strafrechtlich nicht
relevant
nach einem eklat um ein juden
freundliches werk musste vor kurzem
generaldirektoren schumann zurücktreten
im nordafrikanischen tunesien scheint
die demokratie de facto abgeschafft bei
einem referendum haben 95 prozent der
wähler innen für eine neue verfassung
gestimmt bei nur 30 prozent
wahlbeteiligung
die neue verfassung verleiht staatschef
sei deutlich mehr macht es gibt nun
keine instanz mehr die den präsidenten
kontrollieren oder ihn des amtes
entheben kann die opposition hatte zum
wahlboykott aufgerufen
tunesien war das einzige land das aus
den protesten ab ende 2010 in der
arabischen welt als demokratie
hervorgehen
die lage in den deutschen
waldbrandgebieten hat sich zwar leicht
entspannt die feuerwehren vor ort stehen
jedoch weiter vor großen aufgaben im
süden brandenburgs ist noch immer eine
fläche von rund 850 hektar betroffen im
nationalpark sächsische schweiz an der
grenze zu tschechien sind rund 400
feuerwehrleute im einsatz auf hunderten
hektar waldgebiet cornelia schiemenz
berichtet hier soll noch schlimmeres
verhindert werden ein panzer der
bundeswehr schlägt den brandenburg
schmeißen bald der schutzstreifen soll
verhindern dass sich die feuer weiter
ausbreiten die einsatzkräfte haben seit
tagen durch gearbeitet nun ist das
großfeuer unter kontrolle 300 von 800
hektar gelöscht
die stimmung an dich ist ganz gut bloß
wenn man immer wieder sieht man arbeitet
ihr ganzen tag und dann hat man immer
wieder brandnester die abnahme und der
das wetter ist eigentlich bisschen
unberechenbar unberechenbar und
angespannt bleibt die lage auch in der
sächsischen schweiz 250 hektar stehen
hier in flammen die feuerwehrmänner
kämpfen bis zum rand der erschöpfung das
urlaubsparadies in flammen touristen
sind dringend aufgerufen das gebiet zu
verlassen
für alle wälder gilt ein
betretungsverbot wenn ich sehe wie
schlimm dabei aussieht allem wenn man
die guckt oder hinter uns ist es
erschreckend ja dann wäre dafür ja ich
liebe braucht man länger oder natur als
als business und auch die die vom
tourismus leben unterstützen die
verschärften maßnahmen dann ist es halt
so ja aber mir geht es jetzt auch darum
dass ihr niemand zu schaden kommt und
dass mein haus hier auch noch stehen
bleibt das ist mir jetzt ganz wichtig
meine existenz es geht um die existenz
einer ganzen region
die feuer haben den sommertourismus jäh
ausgebremst und die berühmte
kirnitzschtalbahn steht still ihr
betrieb ruht bis auf weiteres
mehr dazu können sie in einem zdf
spezial sehen direkt im anschluss an
diese sendung
heute abend kaum erkennbar das wird ein
heißes halbfinalspiel deutschland gegen
frankreich liebler angriff stark das dfb
team aber mit der besten abwehr im
turnier und trotz des krone ausfalls von
stürmerin klarer bruch motiviert katja
schweder inmitten keys sind denn diana
deutschen spielerinnen die 22
ja alle anderen spielerinnen inklusive
torhüterinnen sind fit es gab keine
weiteren kroner fälle im deutschen team
und für die
erkrankte klarer bühl wird heute die 19
jährige julia brandt von beginn an
spielen das heißt dass die bundes
trainerin martina voss tecklenburg nicht
grundsätzlich am taktischen system etwas
ändert heißt auch dass alexandra popp
vorne im sturm von beginn an wieder
spielen wird und bei dem namen da
leuchteten gestern die augen der
bundestrainer die so begeistert ist von
ihrer team kapitänen weil sie so stark
zurückgekommen ist nach einer langen
langen verletzungspause und hier weiter
über ihre grenzen hinaus zu gehen
scheint ob sie heute wieder trifft wie
in den anderen spielen werden wir sehen
21 uhr ist der anpfiff in milton keynes
deutschland gegen frankreich dann hat
vielleicht auch aufgehört zu regnen
bestimmen sie aber gern ein ab 2025 live
hier im zdf danke katja stresow
england hat es ja schon ins finale
geschafft durch das 14 uhr gestern abend
gegen schweden anfangs die
skandinavierinnen spielbestimmend dann
aber eine fulminante leistungssteigerung
der three lions
der traum vom ersten titel lebt weiter
auf der insel was den männern 2021
verwehrt blieb rückt in greifbare nähe
für die englischen frauen nach ihrem
furiosen auftritt im halbfinale wir
hatten die tore die wir brauchten die
leistung die wir brauchten gegen ein
wirklich gutes schwedisches team
dass sich nach starker anfangsphase dem
druck der gastgeberinnen und beugen muss
bad meat vor der halbzeit die führung
alessia rosso mit dem spektakulären
dritten treffer am ende vier zu null nur
noch ein erfolg im wembley stadion und
es wäre der größte englische triumph
seit dem gewinn der männer-wm 66
ebenfalls in london
start der kanu slalom wm in augsburg bei
und gleich zweimal gold für die
deutschen kajak teams im legendären
olympia eiskanal von 1972 angeführt von
tokio olympiasiegerin ricarda funk
siegte das frauen trio mit jasmin
schornberg und elena willig vor
slowenien ja und bei den männern gewann
hannes aigner mit seinem teamkollegen
noah hegel und stefan hengst vor
großbritannien
silbermedaille gab es auch noch aber
jetzt schnell weiter das was uns schon
technisch enorm aber nicht darstellst du
den lottozahlen die wurde nämlich heute
gezogen ist natürlich mittwoch hier sind
sie die gewinnzahlen lauten 1 16 23 28
29 46 und die superzahl ist die 0 weiter
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und dem zdf text auf seite 5 157
morgen gibt's ruhiges sommerwetter mehr
dazu gleich von katja honnefer und in
der halbzeitpause des wm halbfinales
deutschland frankreich können sie das
heute journal sehen dass es dann gegen
viertel vor zehn mit christian sievers
hier geht es weiter mit dem zdf spezial
[Musik]
guten abend wenn da nicht die
trockenheit wäre könnten sich bestimmt
einige von uns morgen mit dem hoch micra
anfreunden denn das bringt uns ruhiges
sommerwetter und recht tiefe
temperaturen wie vor allen dingen morgen
die küste treffen das ist kalt wird
merken wir aber schon in dieser nacht
zum beispiel in der lüneburger heide da
sinken die werte bis sechs grad das ist
schon sehr frisch für ende juli häufig
geht es runter auf 15 bis 10 grad und
meist ist der himmel klar oder nur
leicht bewölkt das ändert sich auch
morgen im alltag nicht am sonnigsten ist
es dann hier richtung berlin brandenburg
sachsen und auch am oberrhein am
nachmittag kommen dann aus den alpen
heraus einige gewitter heran die
temperaturen liegen morgen an der küste
um die 19 grad sonst sind ist im norden
22 bis 26 im süden 25 bis 31 grad und
der freitag bringt uns dann kräftige
gewitter besonders in bayern
regenschauer und gewitter ziehen am
samstag dann hier ostwärts ab und dann
kommen am sonntag von nordwesten neue
schauer heran aber diese ganzen
regenschauer und gewitter die bringe
nichts in sachen dürre das sind maximal
punktuell so 10 bis 30 liter pro
quadratmeter
guten abend